justices of the highest court refuting
an npr report on alleged spat between
justices it claimed justice gorsuch
refused to mask up despite his colleague
justice sotomayor's concerns npr is
standing by its report even after the
justices came out with an official state
statement saying that report was false
let's bring in tommy larry and fox
nation host tommy great to see you this
was all kind of coming out breaking down
the chief justice put out a statement
during this hour yesterday
and we were all taking it in together
and this is after
outlet after outlet after outlet
headline after headline ran with this
story without even checking
with the justices themselves here's an
example of some of the headlines this is
usa today supreme court justice gorsuch
refused to wear a mask in the courtroom
despite requests from roberts that of
course too was also false supreme court
justice gorsuch refused to wear a mask
despite requests over soda mario's
coving concerns that was cnbc i will
leave these up on the screen rolling
stone newsweek cnn it was everywhere and
not only that
multiple tv networks then ran with the
story watch this
anti-mask insanity has now reached the
highest court in the land risking the
life of your colleague because you just
don't feel like putting a mask on you
neil gorsuch are both a rotten co-worker
dangerous to be near in a pandemic and
tonight's absolute worst can you put a
mask on seriously polite
what kind of workplace is this all of
the other conservative members of the
court are willing to go along with this
why not him
wow tommy
yeah npr didn't just make a bad
assumption here they perpetuated a lie
and so did several other news outlets
but we have to ask ourselves why why are
these news outlets members of the
mainstream media so-called journalists
why are they seeking to sow such
division now we know why democrats might
want division in the country they have
elections to win and they have to pit
themselves against conservatives against
republicans we also know democrats want
to fundamentally change not only the
court but the country so they need to
put out this kind of material this kind
of division but we have to ask ourselves
why is the media invested in doing this
why does the media want to sow division
unless they are doing the bidding for
the democrat party which unfortunately
appears to be the case i just want to
make sure that i put up the official
statements that then came from the court
saying this was absolutely false despite
everything you just heard there uh
gorsuch sotomayor
two nights ago put this together
reporting that justice sotomayor asked
justice gorsuch to wear a mask surprised
us it is false while we may sometimes
disagree about the law we are warm
colleagues and friends then chief just
justice roberts this again happened
during this hour yesterday put out his
own statement i did not request justice
courses or any other justice to wear a
mask on the bench and to your point
about trying to sew division this was a
little bit of that mpr original report
that
tried to obviously pit the justices
against each other by writing this
gorsuch from the beginning of his tenure
has proved a prickly justice not exactly
beloved even by his conservative soul
mates on the court which is astounding
considering the support he has received
in the wake of this false report from
his fellow justices
the liberals in the media and it appears
to be that they are liberals in the
media they want to pit these justices
against each other but they also will
take any opportunity to make any
conservative especially a trump
appointee look bad they have to do that
they have to make conservatives look bad
whether it's the truth or not now these
journalists have not only a duty but an
oath and obligation to seek the truth
and report it not salacious lies not
gossip and i want to also know why their
allegiance to the agenda is more
important than their allegiance to their
profession and to the american people
where it should reside um thank you for
joining us on that i was actually just
trying to dig up there was one of those
outlets uh then tried to walk back their
original headline uh by simply saying
that there's pushback from the court on
the on the previous reporting but not a
whole lot of corrections were made or
retractions were made that we have seen
so far tommy thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else